good company
give me
give me uh education on on this on what
gc is what does it mean so uh gc stands
for good company and uh basically i
started this company probably in about
2017 2018
and we're just like a basically like
here to help artists you feel me in the
bay like i didn't really have any um
backing or support like outside when i
was growing my [ __ ] i couldn't get
people to like help me and help me would
play all this extra [ __ ] playlist and
just none of that so we start kind of
figuring out the game and doing it
ourselves and i kind of got with my
homies and we just started building a
platform to where we're like
if an artist does need help and we love
what they're doing we're able to assist
and accommodate in certain areas whether
that be like marketing content ads
playlists and [ __ ] like that and it's
and it's a it's it's own platform right
so like you go to the youtube page and
there's right so we have a live
performance session platform but we also
do just a bunch of other content and we
kind of started we started a live
performance platform uh last december
and it's kind of like you know like
colors genius
[ __ ] like that just our own in our home
because like
man we had to go we had to go everywhere
to do everything you feel me is like
every time we had to shoot something we
had to go to [ __ ] l.a right right
york or frisco yeah so i was like big on
bringing that home and doing it we
actually went to uh vevo in 2019 and
shot some content with them and i was
telling my team i'm like bro we got to
go home and do this ourselves like we it
shouldn't be we shouldn't have to fly
across the country
to do it so like that was a plan and we
kind of really went home and just made
that [ __ ]